i've not seen you
since that uh incident in 2006
at rock the bells yeah it might have
been that
yeah just going right out the gate with
it well i mean what do you want it's a
notable thing that happened i like it
i uh it was um i mean i i've
told that story a couple times recently
i told it to eric andre
on uh on the podcast we had him on
and uh i guess i only told it that once
yeah
[Laughter]
eric is the kind of guy that would have
tried to pull something like that too
but eric would have got beat up
we don't know eric like we know you
steve right i mean dude i
i when i met i literally like i don't
know i just i felt like kind of
traumatized by that and and not even
traumatized but like
traumatized by feeling guilty you know
like i i've never
for all my uh crazy antics for all for
all the the stuff i
i i do i've never been the guy who tried
to
offend people or upset people you know
like i've always done my
my [ __ ] like at my own expense you know
like i'm the butt of the joke and i'm
like
you know i i don't do like mean or
offensive [ __ ] so uh
yeah that didn't sit well with me and i
remember um bumping into rizza
at some point after that i saw him
somewhere and i was like hey man dude
like
you know uh yeah i just i want to
acknowledge that dude i want to try and
make it right
and rizzo was like dude i i didn't care
you know like
yeah because rizza rizza knows your
heart he knew that
it wasn't done in an offensive manner
but
at that moment in time in that space
with
you know dirty's mother being there and
things nature because even i
didn't really think because you told me
he was going to do it and i was like
steve if you're going to do that
okay i mean no
but um in the space that it happened in
i i wasn't offended by it until
chef brought it to my eyes that the
people who were present may be offended
by it
right see i'm in show mode so when that
was brought to my attention it hit me
like
oh right wow
and i'm pretty sure it hit you like that
too probably like oh yeah
i didn't think of that part of it you
know what i mean and that's how i
basically took it and i think a lot of
the other members
probably took it that way too but some
was genuinely
freaking pissed right yeah for sure man
and uh
boy rayquan turned me into a real [ __ ]
real fast
um i've seen him do that before the
other people so yeah
hey give me what it is bro real quick
for anyone who didn't see the eric andre
episode like what what are you guys
talking about what happened
that's that's a fair question so it was
uh 2006 it was a big rock the bells
uh festival there were uh it was
headlined by wu tang they had all kinds
of
great acts but but wu-tang was last i
was there all day just getting sloppy
drunk
i'm hanging out with method man like in
the back and
i'm telling method man yo when i was
locked up in
uh in la correctional facility in the
twin towers
they took me out of my cell and i was
hanging out with the cops in there and
they said yo
dude you're an odb cell he's always in
here
and uh and i was like man that just made
me feel like i love odb
and you know we were we were like cell
mates man i want to do something like
i want to do something on stage at the
show to uh you know
to like as a tribute to odb you know i
think he'd love it i'm going to get
butt naked i'm going to flip my balls
back and forth and
join us
like that before in my life
i'm going to flip my balls and dig back
and forth i'm going to catch in a
mangina
and while i'm standing there with my
mangina then i'm going to do a perfect
backflip and i'm going to and dude
dude it actually ended up being the best
double backpack flip i ever landed i
never landed one that clean in my life
but yeah so it started and at first it
was all like kind of fun and games we
were joking around backstage like oh man
that's funny
and then methamine came up to me a
little while later before
before they went on he said he says you
can't do it dude he says they're gonna
kick your ass
and i said let him kick my ass man otb
would probably love that
and uh okay truck yeah this is probably
during the pcp days right
right and then when you know it's like
so many things dude it's like oh yeah
let that and then when it actually
happens i'm like i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry
and this was on stage oh yeah do you
break one so i did it
like like method man said odb's mom was
there like
it was this like tribute to him and you
know i i grabbed the mic i'd do my thing
and
like uh and it was actually kind of
nobody seemed that upset at first and
then they played like shimmy yeah
and and brooklyn zoo and it was like
we're all having a good time but then
all of a sudden like
rayquan just grabs me by the neck with
both hands and he's like
yo you're gonna apologize man that was
disrespectful on the mic
oh yeah oh yeah he said stop the music
he stopped the music to grab you by the
neck
grab me now that i have your attention
it was it was a um like you know an
assembly moment when the principal walks
into the room
and because all the students are being
too right and he steps up on stage and
says something like
we don't do that here at mckenna high
school
no wait steve sit your ass down before i
call your mom
you know we know her she's been here a
few times
but damn the lapd for that man talking
about this is dirty cell what kind of
[ __ ] harassment [ __ ] is that
yeah i don't know man they listed off uh
they said um who else was cells was that
they said they said what this is we call
this robert downey jr blog because i was
in protective custody
see that that's so [ __ ] tacky right
there
you know i mean like
go ahead it's all good dude i'm not i'm
not
i'm not like uh i'm not disagreeing with
you they said
it's like a robert downey junior blog
this is where all the celebrities come
it's
protective custody so nobody gets like
you know our high profile inmates
they're like we had tommy lee robert
downey jr you know
like odb is always in here they said
you're in as hell
yeah i am and i didn't even you know
honestly i just thought
i felt honored to be an odb cell
[Music]
in the mental game it is that you know
they
like they're proud that they had these
and this is some of these celebrities
lowest freaking moments
oh yeah yeah who've been rehabilitated
by the way a lot of them
yeah by the way so for them to still
have those
that that is just terrible man yeah
they're probably in their jail so like
can i get a selfie with you dude
oh dude like the uh the cops were i just
got my back tattoo
but the movie wasn't out yet so nobody
knew about it and the cops were all
taking pictures with my back
yeah i went in their office they took me
out of my cell like into their office
that was cool as hell right i did i was
like man would have been cooler
if they would have let your ass go
[Laughter]
for sure what was your history with the
wu tang uh before that event
um we had method man on wild boys with
us which was such a huge honor
yeah there was another time when you
were here for uh
uh it was like the night before like the
i don't know maybe the bet awards
and i think it was that because at the
hotel i went to go hang with matt the
man
oh yeah so you guys were tight i mean i
don't know if it was
how tight we were but he was just always
a bro you know man was always just so
cool to me
and uh so i met up with method man at
his hotel
and uh yeah i remember you're tripping
too because you're like dude
here in california you can just go to a
store
and buy weed it's like you know now new
york always had a dialed though because
even though it was illegal in new york
they had like the delivery system
you know some guy shows up on a bicycle
and gives you like good ass weed
but it wasn't legal you know here in l.a
then mess like yo down just went to a
store and bought this like this is
insane he's rolling up uh a blunt
i forget with what you had some funny
thing about how you were the master of
rolling blunts
like something
yeah and uh and then so so
so we're smoking this blunt and all of a
sudden i think i'm like yo dude
[ __ ] hey meth [ __ ] throw the blood
across your hotel room i'll catch it in
my mouth
got a big old hotel room he throws this
lit blood across the room and i
and i gotta catch it right but i catch
it the wrong way so i got the [ __ ]
i catch the burning end of my lips but i
don't care i'm not going to drop this
thing man this is my shot
so i i catch it i catch and
it just straight burns my lip and i'm
like yo dude
do i look like i have herpes
you remember that meth yes i do that's
facts he wanted to catch a blunt in his
mouth and [ __ ]
but did you tape that steve
dude i have the footage and i've still
never done anything with it
guess what i have the number 30 ranked
hot sauce on all of amazon
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon and buy stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude